some of you were really scared right now
aren't you understand I've been there
I've been there where things were so out
of my control that I couldn't and didn't
know what to do and I couldn't breathe
and it's funny it doesn't matter how
many years go by and it was about was
1988 when we filed bankruptcy so 40
years ago almost you know 30 years ago
over 30 but uh I stood - decades right I
mean I still feel it I still remember
that feeling in your throat that feeling
when your stomach is trying to come up
through your throat that feeling of
pounding in the back of your head from
stress and just the fear I didn't have
any money I couldn't get any money and
my lights got cut off and my water got
cut off and I got babies and some of you
are facing that right now right now let
me tell you if you were not afraid in
the middle of something like that you
would be a psychopath
so it does mean you have mental health
if you're afraid when times are scary
that would be a normal thing to be
afraid about things that are not
happening but just might happen now
that's known as a worrywart right and
Dale Carnegie used to say wrote a book
on worry and he the thesis of the book
was 80% of the things we worry about
never occur I don't know if you can
actually statistically cover that but I
think life will tell you that's pretty
close I don't know if I can confirm that
you know with actual research but he was
making more of a metaphorical statement
but I completely agree 80% of the stuff
I have worried about in my life never
happened is there some about all of us
we we all anticipate worst-case
scenarios and very few people anticipate
best-case scenarios and live with that
very few people do that now you need to
be able to do both because you need to
be able to look and see when you know
something's turning down and you prefer
prayer for it and you you're smart about
it and all that kind of stuff but I mean
we've got some small businesses
right now that everyone's all jumping up
and down and clapping and so happy that
they were so patriotic and so forward
thinking that they closed down for the
coronavirus the problem is they'll never
reopen they're gone and the families
that worked there lost their jobs now
some of you that are freaking out
coronavirus freakazoids you are so happy
that they're not operating but the
families aren't happy they're gone that
family has lost their job and that that
restaurant is never going to reopen
because there won't be money and they've
gone broke because they were forced to
close and not have customers and they're
gone they're gone well day that's just
whether there's a big keg in have the
virus spreading I don't want the virus
to spread either I'm just telling you
the realities are that those servers and
those chefs and those dishwashers they
don't have a job anymore
those people that worked in that hotel a
hotel is gone it's not going to reopen
in some cases now some of them open some
of the big ones are reopen some of the
some of the restaurants have your good
shape they'll reopen but some of these
cities I mean when you take the pictures
I saw in New York City this morning that
it looked like the zombie apocalypse
there's not a soul on the street I've
never seen that in my life and I'm 60
years old in New York City and let me
just tell you that's a lot of businesses
that are never gonna come back that's a
lot of them because those empty streets
mean there is zero revenue and they are
gone and so there's a there's a another
there is a thing to be terrified of and
it's unemployment the thing to be
terrified of your family has no income
that's not that's a thing to be
terrified of and you know some of you
that have gone completely berserk have
not considered that in your hysteria
while you were shopping in a grocery
store who did was open and who did have
people there you're just not using good
critical thinking skills so do I want
the voters to spread de rim she's
irresponsible oh shut up
that's just stupid kind of asinine
person would actually want a virus to
spread or be irresponsible intentionally
causing harm to people that's just dumb
of course we don't want that that's
ridiculous but what we do want and I
love small business small business is
the backbone of America and a whole
bunch of them are gone and next week a
whole bunch more of them will be gone if
we don't get them back open again and
the families that used to work there are
on the street unemployed and if that's
you here's what you do if it all
possible do not cash out your retirement
if at all possible pick up a job
delivering food because nobody's open
you know get with get with uber and
deliver things and you can get you can
get some income coming in get some
income coming in and then you take care
of food first at your house this is your
budget priorities shelter second I'm
sorry utilities second keep the lights
and the water on make sure there's food
on your table then the next thing you do
is you you take care of shelter you keep
your house payment or your rent current
and then transportation food shelter
transportation and utilities these are
your the four walls of your house if you
keep that going you keep enough of that
going until you get re-employed back
into your career field just by keeping
the wolf away from your door you've done
a great job and you've turned the corner
in a personal financial crisis caused by
hysteria and you'll make the turn and
I've been there and I've walked lots of
families through that while they might
not have had anal nation around them at
the same time doing the same thing but
I've walked lots of families through who
were down to the last knob and we go
water what can we do to create income
what can we do to create income what can
we do to create income let's get some
income coming in get you a leafblower
rich people are afraid to leave so let's
go baby I mean let's go let's get you a
why sure everybody's got mildew
somewhere it right I mean let's get
things going here what can we do and we
babysit can we dog walk what can we do I
don't care I'm not too proud to do
anything I'll shovel something let's go
I'm a I just got to make a little bit of
money and keep some food on my baby's
table and then once I do that I could
keep the blights on in my baby's room
that's all I got to do and that's you
get your head around that and you get
back out there instead of sitting around
terrified in the corner sucking your
thumb in a fetal position you get back
out there and you start kicking doors
again and it's hard because you're
scared and you're overwhelmed but in the
middle of that use all of that fear as
energy to go make some money and create
an income as fast as you can as ridicul
if it's 'as believe me there's lots of
people delivering food pizzas and people
right now
lots of them and some of these
industries have gone up really up there
they're busiest crud right now so go get
in that go make you some money and keep
the wolf away from the door meaning
you're gonna get the four walls taken
care of and then you can come back to
the baby steps and stuff later and I'll
help you but that's how you do survival
mode that's how you turn the corner and
terrorists I terrifying at times